so in this video I want to talk about
how to burn more calories without
exercise and without eating less is it
possible it absolutely is possible if
you have the right information most
people have this idea that I need to
exercise more and eat less calories
because one pound of fat is 3500
calories so if I just take the total
calories it takes to run my body let's
say it's an average 1,900 calories okay
and I eat less than that and I burn off
extra calories boom problem solved I
lose the weight and of course the main
recommendation that people are given and
this is based on this website called nks
dot uk'
they get over 43 million views a month
and this is some of the things that they
will tell you to do to lose weight
number one do not skip your breakfast ok
number two eat regular meals
number three keep plenty of fruit and
vegetables I agree with the vegetables
walk more and get more steps drink more
water consume higher fiber foods use a
smaller plate and last don't ban any
specific food ok so you don't want to
ban any specific food I don't know why
they're recommending that but their
biggest thing is that you must eat
everything in moderation here's the big
problem you have two types of stored
fuel you have stored sugar as glycogen
and you have stored fat the amount of
stored sugar that an average person has
is about 1,700 calories okay not a lot
the average person who's not overweight
is carrying about a hundred thousand
calories of fat on their body so the
real question is how to burn more fat
calories because I don't think the goal
is just to burn off your sugar reserves
and then get really really hungry for
carbohydrates right and not tapping the
fat doing everything in moderation
we'll only cause you to burn off your
sugar but it will not cause you to tap
into fat so if we want to focus in not
just burning up our sugar few but
tapping into the actual fat
we must not treat all the type of
calories the same ok certain calories we
can have more certain ones we can do
less and some we can do moderation like
for example protein yes
each approaching a moderation that would
be a smart idea
SARS the carbs we need to reduce that
because if you want to maximize your fat
burning and tap into only fat the way to
do that is simply to bring your carbs as
close to zero as possible okay so let's
say we have zero and then we have five
carbs ten carbs per day 15 carbs 20
carbs per day right or through here is
where you going to start seeing some
good results the greater the carb the
less your body's ability to tap into fat
fuel and as you feed your body less and
less carb your metabolism actually
speeds up because you actually heal a
condition called
insulin resistance which is behind a
slow metabolism realize that exercise
only is responsible for about 15% of
your weight loss but 85% is diet so it's
not as significant as you might think ok
but now let's talk about how to lose
weight without reducing your calories
let's say for example you're consuming
1,950 calories per day and you're doing
3 meals maybe some snacks whatever and
so each meal would be about 650 calories
ok three meals a day if you were to
start reducing the frequency of meals ok
you skip your breakfast but we take
those calories and we put them into a
lunch and a dinner with only two meals
you will start to lose more weight
because of the nature of just going on a
longer fast and the fact that every time
you eat you trigger insulin and that's
what converts into fat so the less
eating less insulin more weight loss so
you go from 3 meals a day
down to two meals keep your total
calories at nineteen hundred and fifty
ok
and then you want to take it to the next
level because if you're doing two meals
a day no snacks and you're fasting your
hunger is going to go way down and the
rule of thumb is you don't want to eat
unless you are hungry which means that
you're going to be able to have one meal
a day and not have to eat breakfast or
lunch giving you a total of about 23
hours of fasting and this is without
cutting your calories down if you kept
the same amount of calories as three
meals you would lose a lot more weight
now the problem that you're gonna run
into is that you're actually burning
your own fat reserve when you're fasting
okay so it's not like you're starving
you are eating but you're eating your
own fat so for you to sit down and have
a meal that is nineteen hundred and
fifty calories is difficult to consume
that but you could what most people end
up doing is eating less calories not
because they're trying to lose weight
just because they're having a hard time
digesting it but the cool thing is
though when you're eating less the need
for nutrients goes down because your
body is in a recycle mode so you're
recycling more than nutrients so this is
how you burn more fat calories without
eating less and without exercising you
reduce the frequency of eating keep your
calories the same but just make sure
you're reducing certain calories but not
others go ahead and try this and see for
yourself if you're liking this content
please subscribe now and I will actually
keep you updated on future videos